hello and welcome to the daily climate
show coming up
don't lose hope and don't lose focus the
message from the un as diplomats gather
in germany to review progress on climate
action
sales of electric vehicles rockets have
made a wider slump in the uk's car
industry
and as a new law comes into effect
banning the trade of ivory in the uk
campaigners fear it might be too late
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show here on sky news where we track the
changes happening to the world look at
the progress that is being made to deal
with those changes and of course hear
from the people who are coming up with
the solutions
now the war in ukraine and energy
security will be weighing on the minds
of international climate diplomats as
they gather in bond today to assess
progress
on international climate action now cop
26 in glasgow feels like a long time ago
now doesn't it but countries then we're
united on the need for quicker action by
cutting carbon emissions well today the
world is distracted and many see climate
action stalling
in her opening speech the u.n climate
chief patricia espinosa emphasized the
need for much faster progress
we need decisions and actions now and it
is incumbent on all nations to make
progress here in bonn in the coming two
weeks
and we must understand that climate
change is moving
exponentially
we can no longer afford to make
just incremental progress
we must move these negotiations along
more quickly
the world expects it
while our europe correspondent siobhan
robbins joins me now and siobhan what
progress or lack thereof has there been
since glasgow
well if we cast our minds back to
november last year you'll remember some
of those pledges from glasgow so moving
away from coal cutting emissions halting
deforestation helping some of the
poorest countries to deal with the
impacts of climate change and frankly
some of the progress over the last six
seven months on some of those topics has
been pretty depressing so for example in
terms of deforestation we've actually
seen record levels of deforestation in
the amazon
also in terms of helping some of those
poorest countries we're still not
hitting the target for the amount of
money to be given to those countries
also coal because of the problems with
ukraine because of the problems with
energy security some countries are now
clinging on to coal or even investing in
it so it hasn't been a very pretty
picture in that sense but there have
been a few glimmers of hope so for
example china has seen the longest
sustained
sustained drop in co2 emissions and
that's mainly down to a drop in output
in cement factories and steel however
they are still investing a lot in gas
and coal so we need to see if that
emissions drop continues
um so siobhan what are the main aims
then of this meeting in bonn
so the meeting will last for the next
two weeks and essentially what this is
is the kind of like looking back to
glasgow and saying what do we need to do
but then also looking forward to cop 27
which will take place in egypt and
saying what can we then build on so
they're going to be looking at things
like getting cash for poorer countries
uh how to cut emissions uh how to move
away from coal things like that it's
basically implementation and policy
and we have heard from the u.n climate
chief today who was saying that they
can't afford to dordle that climate
change has set its own pace and that
they have to react to it but also
issuing a rallying cry saying despite
the other crises facing the world they
have to focus on climate change
shivan thank you she won robins there in
berlin
well let's get some of today's other
climate news now in australia's prime
minister has offered indonesia a
115 million pound climate partnership as
an attempt to deepen the diplomatic
relationship between the two countries
now starting their meeting by riding on
bamboo bicycles around the presidential
palace anthony albanese and president
joko widodo discuss regional cooperation
and security now the new australian
leader also offered assistance for
indonesia's new green high-tech capital
which is due to be relocated from
jakarta to the island of borneo
the rapid growth in sales of electric
vehicles was the only bright spot in
rather gloomy news for the uk's car
industry today
car sales overall dropped by nearly 21
last month the second weakest may in
three decades is after 2020 when
showrooms were of course closed because
of the lockdown
but electric vehicles sales jumped by
nearly 18
and so the faster the growth in
battery-powered vehicles then of course
the faster emissions from the transport
sector will drop
and the u.n secretary general has called
for a new way for the world to measure
success
in an appeal for more sustainable
economic growth antonio guterres tweeted
when we destroy forests over fish or
burn coal
then we are increasing gross domestic
products it's time to change an
accountant system he continued that
counts the destruction of the planets as
if it was the products of richness
the new law banning the trade of ivory
throughout the uk comes into effect
today elephant population
have long been in decline due to habitat
loss and of course hunting for their
tasks so the new law has been welcomed
by conservationists however an
investigation by international wildlife
charity born free has uncovered evidence
that large volumes of ivory are still
being sold online
threatening the survival of wild
elephants fraser malt has this report
protecting the earth's largest land
mammal is a battle fort on many fronts
the ban on ivory sales is just one of
them and from today it'll be illegal for
ivory to be sold to in or from the uk
one of the biggest threats to elephants
is the trade in ivory the illegal trade
in ivory and by having no legal markets
you were closing doors for people to
launder illegal ivory through those
marketplaces so you are giving them a
bit of a reprieve unsurprisingly the
internet has become a prime resource for
the ivory dealers
to avoid ivory bans already in place on
some internet marketplaces unscrupulous
dealers often describe their items as
being made of bone horn or antler or
from artificial materials like bakelite
resin or ivorine
figures from the bourne free foundation
suggest the online market for ivory in
the uk sees almost 2 000 listings a
month worth over a million pounds
although not always easily identified by
far the most common source of the ivory
being sold on the internet is from
elephants
but the act doesn't prohibit selling
elephant ivory alternatives from other
living animals with tusks or teeth or
even from extinct species like the
mammoth which raises concerns that the
covert selling of elephant ivory could
increase along with the threat of other
animals being exploited
this law is a significant improvement on
the
previous ivory regulations and
we welcome it but of course we have some
reservations about not including
non-elephant ivory species for example
by only banning elephant ivory ivory
from other animals such as walruses and
hippos will increase in demand
conservationists question why anyone
would want to own items like these when
their very existence increases the
threat to one of the world's most
intelligent and iconic creatures
fraser moored sky news
and that's it from me for now thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]